how to zester Lemon the important part  is not to zest any of the pith watch the  following technique and I'll show you  how we've got these original graters  really important when we use this this  is the fine zester not the big rough one  not the one for slicing and not the  other one for grating this little one  here onto a plate because it's always  easier to lift off from the plate than  it is the board and the most important  thing about zesting a lemon is nice long  strokes but twisting the lemon round  every time we go down we twist  same with the orange and same with the  lime  little tap  if you go too far  let me just show you look you've got  that white bitter pith that destroys the  wonderful zesty flavor and look that's  what we're looking for there this really  nice vibrant lemon zest